It is my pleasure to welcome to the program
today, Dr. Peniel Joseph, who's the founding
director of the Center for the Study of Race
and Democracy.
Professor of history at the University of
Texas at Austin.
Also author of the book The Sword and the
Shield The Revolutionary Lives of Malcolm
X and Martin Luther King Junior.
So great to have you on.
Thank you for having me.
So to begin with, we've seen over the last
four to six months some of the larger protests
that this country has seen.
I guess we can say in the sort of medium term
since the Occupy Wall Street days of some
years ago.
And one of the great debates that has surfaced
is in the context of the teachings of Malcolm
X and the teachings of Martin Luther King.
What would they say about the protests today?
What would their views be about the tactics
that would be considered either valid or moral
or productive for achieving change today?
And and my instinct is that a lot of people
are ascribing to these two men what they already
believe to be the right answer.
And so I want to start by going back to the
history.
Where can how can we frame this conversation?
Well, I think the best way to frame it is
to look at the convergences between Malcolm
X and Martin Luther King Junior.
So even though we think of Malcolm as the
political sword of the 1960s and we think
of King as sort of this nonviolent human rights
shield, one of the things I argue in my new
book is that they really converge.
Malcolm X is arguing for radical black dignity.
King is arguing for radical black citizenship.
And over time, they come to use that political
sword and shield.
Malcolm X goes from talking about self-defense.
And certainly this global revolution to saying
that the civil rights movement should be a
human rights movement.
And he talks about the ballot or the bullet
and actually used it using voting rights and
using democratic institutions.
But he also always reserves the right of indigenous
people for self-defense.
A king goes from talking about nonviolence,
and he's always talking about no use of violence.
But he starts to look at civil disobedience
as a tool.
He calls it a nonviolent political sword.
By 1965.
That could paralyze cities in order to achieve
racial justice and human rights for black
people, but for all people.
Right.
So when we think about the Black Lives Matter
movement with that movement, does is it uses
both King's notion of radical black citizenship
and Malcolm X, his notion of radical black
dignity.
And we think about what it Malcolm mean by
that.
He meant eradicating systemic racism and defeating
white supremacy globally and allowing black
people to have political self-determination.
King is going to say that citizenship is more
than voting rights.
It's actually a right to an income, a guaranteed
job, affordable housing.
King talks about food, justice and, of course,
dies.
Trying to lead a poor people's campaign took
Occupy Washington, D.C.. David.
So you mentioned Occupy Wall Street, but King
tried to occupy Washington, D.C. in 1968.
One of the things in the last six months looking
at interviews from decades ago, but with both
Malcolm X and Martin Luther King, one of the
refrains that I frequently heard from Martin
Luther King that I didn't find Malcolm X using,
and I'm curious whether it is it is actually
a distinction or maybe I didn't look hard
enough.
Was Martin Luther King asserting that one
of the risks sometimes of going over into
violence is that it ends up disproportionately
hurting the very people who these Moate movements
are actually trying to help?
So sort of a two part question.
Is it true that that is a difference and that
we did not hear that specific idea from Malcolm
X?
And is it is it accurate?
Why say that Malcolm talks about even Steven?
He talks about an eye for an eye?
I think when we think about Malcolm X, he
talks about the man now what happened in Kenya.
He's really thinking about and supporting
anticolonial movements, anti imperialist movements.
He supports the Cuban revolution.
He supports the Algerian revolution.
He's supporting revolutions all over the place.
So he's not saying exactly what King says
there, where, look, if we were to achieve
or try to enact guerrilla warfare, we're going
to suffer the disproportionate losses, which
I think King is correct in in saying I think
Malcolm's more thinking about this global
political revolution.
And remember, Malcolm's alive during the age
where Africa is decolonizing, where Latin
America and the Caribbean and South America.
This is you think about from the 1940s all
the way into the 80s, in the 90s.
The world is really on fire.
Right?
The last African country is gonna be South
Africa with the freedom of Nelson Mandela.
But we think about Central America, Latin
America, the Caribbean.
There are still battles being waged when we
think about Nicaragua.
We think about El Salvador.
When we think about the world, the world continues
to Brazil and different parts of South America.
There continues to be unrest and upheaval
where indigenous people are arguing for the
right for what political self-determination
and liberation and freedom.
So Malcolm's always on that side.
I do think what we'll see where they really
converge.
By 1964 is that Malcolm who takes his HOJ
to Mecca.
And remember, Malcolm is a part of this global
Islamic community.
Right.
Malcolm was always a Muslim.
Whether he's in the nation of Islam or he
takes the hij, but he starts to say that sincere
whites can be part of the movement.
Right.
If whites are willing to give up white privilege
and racism, they can be part of this movement,
which he calls a global human rights movement.
And he also says that this at Oxford University,
David, in 1964, one of the best debates and
the BBC carries this.
This debate where Malcolm receives a standing
ovation.
Does a 30 minute debate.
And he's actually it's this is very this is
an interesting historical nugget.
He's actually defending Barry Goldwater's
phrase.
Extremism in defense of liberty is no vice.
But for different ideological reasons than
Barry Goldwater.
Right.
Barry Goldwater is the conservative hero of
the American right.
And he used that term to defend racial segregation.
Malcolm used the term extremism in defense
of liberty is no vice to defend his atom.
His adage of by any means necessary liberation,
by any means necessary freedom, citizenship,
by any means necessary.
And he tells the students, multiracial audience
at Oxford University.
He says that he's willing to align with any
person, no matter what the color of their
skin.
As long as they want to end the miserable
condition on the face of this earth.
Now, I always found those words very, very
profound for Malcolm, because you can see
just the evolution.
You see the evolution with King.
King becomes this man on fire.
The last three years of his life, I mean,
he's an anti imperialist.
He's a radical.
He becomes a revolution revolutionary where
he breaks with the Johnson administration.
The Riverside Church speech, April 4th, 1967,
in New York.
King says that the United States of America
is the greatest purveyor of violence in the
world.
And he's he says there comes a time when silence
is betrayal.
David.
And he says that it's going to be a bitter
but beautiful struggle.
And he criticizes the United States.
He says, people told me to be nonviolent in
Selma.
And when I say be nonviolent in Hanoi and
they're bombing and they're they're putting
napalm on children, on children.
They say that I'm anti-American.
So he tells us that the three biggest evils
facing humanity are militarism, racism and
materialism.
So King is this extraordinary figure.
And King by 67 is always also saying that
rioting is the language of the unheard of
the oppressed.
So everybody who's saying that right now,
Dr. King, would be a..
BLM or anti these protests.
They have it exactly wrong.
Dr. King said the roots of unrest and chaos
in the United States were based on white supremacy
and poverty.
He says it's the Kerner Commission in October
of 1967.
He says it during a Southern Christian Leadership
Conference keynote speech where he says the
halls of the U.S. Congress are running wild
with racism.
He says that before a speech to the American
Psychological Association, where he says the
biggest threat to American democracy is white
violence and white chaos, and white people
are hypocritically saying that if there was
peace, there could be racial progress.
But they are the origins of the chaos in Watts
in Detroit everywhere, terms of police brutality,
poverty, racial segregation.
So we think about King.
King is not this milquetoast nice guy is giving
people hugs.
He's a nonviolent revolutionary.
And we stop king.
Our memory.
National memory.
It stops with Selma or sometimes stops in
63 with the march on Washington because we
don't want to face the revolutionary kings.
So clearly, the some of the stories that we
we are told about both Malcolm X and Martin
Luther King are made are certainly oversimplified.
And maybe one note when the reality is is
more complicated.
I want to go back to something you said.
You talked about the the the sort of guidelines
that Malcolm X expressed about what in what
way can white folks credibly be be part of
the movement?
And I'm really interested in that, because
the general question I want to ask you is,
what do you believe the views of these two
men would be about modern identity politics?
And the view I've expressed before is that
on the one hand, using identity as either
a cudgel or a way to silence people.
I think is is is a disaster.
An example that I've pointed out was the way
in which the women's march leadership kept
out Jewish women because they were not intersectional
enough in the right way.
I'm very much against that.
On the other hand, our identity informs our
experience.
And of course, we should be paying particular
attention to what one's experience has to
say about solving a particular problem.
And I think that that's where the right goes
wrong in this kind of umbrella denunciation
of identity as even something relevant to
talk about.
So all of that being said, what how would
these two men, Malcolm X and Martin Luther
King, view what in today's language is called
identity politics?
Yeah, I think that they would be supportive,
but they would want new wants to it.
Right.
So Malcolm Martin, people like James Baldwin.
And here's where, you know, I probably would
say when we think about identity politics,
David, historically, there's always been identity
politics in the United States.
It's just that they were based on SIST gender,
white male wasps who were very, very rich,
which, by the way, still exists in some movements
on the American right, like the Tea Party
movement and others.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
So these these these things in a de facto
way and sometimes in a very vicious way.
We're anti Semitic, anti black, anti woman
anti.
People of color, anti-war.
Folks who are nonces gender, who are LGBTQ.
So we have to say that.
And what we did with that original identity
politics, David, is that we said that was
universal.
That was the universality.
That identity, whether it's Washington or
Jefferson, was the key to the world to unlock
human potential.
And that's why when we would read.
Faulkner or Walt Whitman?
You think Shakespeare?
Not necessarily even reading stuff by white
women.
When you thought with the classics were right.
You're not reading stuff by Jews.
You're not reading stuff by Muslims.
You're not reading stuff by black people.
So we have to say the original, but the original
identity politics has everything to do with
race.
But it's it's a white supremacist, very elitist,
classist, hetero normative identity politics.
We're going to pause our conversation with
Dr. Peniel Joseph.
They're the full interview and it
is extensive.
We'll be available on
my YouTube channel, YouTube dot
com slash The David Pakman Show